here's a reboot I guess Halloween yes is
it totally and what you're doing to
Michael Myers is very interesting yeah
we're uh you know my good buddy David
Greene that I've known since college he
was my roommate and my next-door
neighbor my freshman year of college and
so we've been friends for a long time
we've worked together and uh yeah he
told me that he was being approached to
direct a new installment of Halloween
and he knew I was a huge fan of the
series so he asked I wanted to write it
with him so yeah we've been we've been
cracking away on that we're going to
shoot it this fall so it's starting over
like is it starting from the first one
or is it starting from where their last
one left off uh it's it's not a reboot
it's not going to be a rehash it's a
continuation of Michael Myers but where
we're choosing to continue it from
you'll have to see when it begins up
that that's the question all like
Halloween fans I'm a big Halloween fan
and it's like there are a lot of points
like if you're just starting from the
last mouton last movie was Rob Zombie's
Halloween - you know I love Rob Zombie
and it was not Rob's finest work I love
Rob Zombie - I think like Devil's
Rejects I think it's such an awesome
gnome and uh but yeah you know I mean
it's funny because watching these like
you know Dave and I have been I'd always
I'd already seen all these movies anyway
but I've really been studying them now
and just thinking about all the people
that have gotten hired to like make a
Michael xB yeah I'm just trying to avoid
any mistakes that those people might
have made you should you're a sequel to
you should just say like yeah we got the
next Halloween and pick up right after
season of the witch yeah Michael Myers
isn't even in this thing yeah season of
the witch yes we have Michael Myers I
know you guys are making not
supernatural so you just have them like
in a temp job I can lock down back to
killing people yeah so you don't want
you didn't want him to be supernatural
did you feel that hurt the movies well
you know what I started as soon as you
can start like the first Halloween is
scary [ __ ] and the second Halloween is
scary but not as scary and then from
there it's it isn't as scary and I
really think that what happens with it
is that he basically becomes
Frankenstein he's right yeah no matter
what anyone hits him with he's not going
to die there's no suspense thinking that
maybe someone will escape and you know
that everyone in that movie is just
designed for him to kill in a cool way
except for one person yeah they're paper
targets and so yeah we're just trying to
play with that and play with what people
would expect but also just make him real
and not
take him real by giving him some crazy
backstory they're just sort of like
getting back to the basics of the first
Halloween you know just scary movies are
a silent rage do you ever see that with
Chuck Norris oh yeah he's fighting
sounds like a goddamn Christmas Carol no
no no it was scary it was this guy and
he was they going to use a maniac or
whatever but he was a human being yeah
and what was so scary was that he was a
human being
that's what saw me he wasn't
supernatural he was just a psychopath
who was kind of hard to kill yeah now
he's one of the scariest movies ever
seen from what I remember yeah I mean
that's what that to me that's what
horrors like you have to be able to
imagine that you could be in that
situation and so honestly even the
moment they made Laurie and Michael
Myers siblings it also makes it not
quite as scary Michael is not coming
after you yeah I go he's trying to kill
his sister you know and so all that kind
of stuff to us is like those are the
things that I think took a really
amazing idea and took it somewhere
wasn't quite as effective although the
hospital though the isolation in the
hospital was amazing and they did the
same thing than The Godfather when
they're coming to kill Vito the
isolation in the hospital is great
there's nothing scarier in a movie than
like an empty hospital yeah home yeah
yeah it's just a French you know that
that's supposed to be busy so it's empty
this is a problem yeah I'm [ __ ]
happening you know for Busta Rhymes in
it and like follow up h2o or whatever we
did we've had I think so are you a
horror movie guy I am I
you know that's if I were if I'm to
watch anything it'll usually be like a
horror film that's what I always usually
go to ever since I was a kid I would
just go to pick the most fucked-up box
at the video store and try to convince
my parents to let me rent it so when you
were doing like like when you were
making your own something when you did
foot fishway and all that stuff was
there a thought in your head because
usually like horror movie fans will want
to make that low-budget if you're going
to make a low-budget movie it's going to
be a low-budget horror movie is that
something you always wanted to do yeah I
always wanted to just make lots of
different types of films you know so
that's why it's cool to do something
like alien uh you know like a weird
sci-fi big story like that but yeah I
mean horror has always been something
that we've always talked about trying to
make it also feels like it's one of the
genres that people actually still show
up in the movie theater forum yeah
unfortunately comedy it's like comedy
fans usually don't like go buy tickets
and go see a movie on Friday night are
usually at home stoned what you know
other stuff but you know so it's like I
think that with comedy it's like that's
how it's a kid it's a horror genre right
now to get people to show up for you
know yeah well you and to with the I
feel I was ask you something about the
horror movies there's no rating system
now on Netflix I always watch trying to
find a good horror movie tonight or even
a bad one like a purposely bad one but
now the rating system has changed it's
really hard times up thumbs down yeah so
I could do is know like hardly in the
information like I was looking for a
good one star horror movie click I'm sad
you got to go to color or the cover
artist where it's at you know yeah I
always used to like love that like the
cover of chopping mall I just remember
that was amazing in a funhouse I don't
know if you ever seen how early that's I
love that like the the one liner on that
was like pay to get in play to get out
Motel hell all my Rory Calhoun motor how
is so gay why carry all your doing just
burying people to the next they're next
yeah planting them there and I think
they're making a human farm
did you really a cattle have ever ask
you this but maybe I have did your
mother perform sermons using puppets yes
you did have we talked about that I
don't know why I never had my memories
your [ __ ] so so brand-new interview to
me um what kind of puppets uh
you know the kind that you put your
hands in yeah yeah you know when I grew
all the way that sounds like a horror
movie yeah yeah they're really children
yeah when I grew up I grew up in a very
in my parents were pretty religious we
uh you know we went to church every week
and my parents were like involved in the
church and yeah at some point my mom and
my dad started doing like puppet
ministry they would like they like built
a stage and they would like do the
children's sermons with puppets and yeah
it was very I have all those puppets I
kept them all but then my parents got
divorced and then the church turned
their back on my mom so we never did
puppet ministry ever Wow because of the
divorce sure the church was like you're
not welcome here your dad is still
welcome uh oh he's a man so they they
thought it was her fault I'm sure Wow
did you hate them for that we ever went
to church ever again after that you
didn't really yeah
Wow I think you know what you your whole
life you're going to church and you're
being a faithful servant and they don't
they stay treat your mom poorly and you
say enough what it did that open your
eyes or did that make you feel a certain
way yeah we
one of those things were like I never
wanted to go to church to begin with and
then you're just there like you guys are
[ __ ] on top of it like you just gave
me a ring mom can't go I won't go don't
worry mom I won't go yes I given up
something for Lent that you hate so yeah
I'm going to give up lentil soup we'll
just do these puppet shows for ourselves
you know nothing I think uh I mean
they're like real-deal puppets you know
like you can get up to an elbow in some
of those puppets and what were the pot
what were the puppet was Jesus one or
when no they were all he playing they
were all just people yeah that's weird
no no I said I've been really weird
would they act out a story from the
Bible how it would actually think they
were all just like stories with like
little religious undertones to him you
know did she keep doing the puppet shows
after she left the church no no I say
all just stayed in a box that no my
parents were moving and I found that box
like can I keep these I don't know what
to do with them but I have them all you
want to display them I'll bring back bad
memories no they don't bring back bad
memories I want to do something with
them but I don't know what yet I want to
use them for evil
you should play a guy who's a puppet
person that's all I have how do I pick
me and go yeah I'm not going to selling
ideas puppet person is the [ __ ] gym
that's a good name for horribly the
puppet first puppet person I'm sure it
is I'm sure I'm sure the reason they
called
well there is the puppet master a puppet
man yeah yeah what was that that's a guy
classic yeah it was a there was all
these little puppets that would come to
life yeah but they were more like
marionettes yeah marionettes they would
likely end up the ass puppet yeah the
other movie that I felt like was in that
same range was Ghoulies did you ever see
yes
no I remember I had like a horrible
memory from that because I was a kid and
I asked my that was that that was the
gremlins Ripple yes and I asked my uncle
for Goonies for Christmas and I got
[ __ ] Ghoulies and uh and I only had
like I think like because at that time
VHS tapes member they used to be like
$100 shilling so I had like three movies
in [ __ ] Ghoulies as one I didn't ever
know what to do with it cuz I didn't
really want it as part of my collection
so I would just keep it in the desk but
it was that green ghuli coming out of
the toilet and it was like what they
tried to scare you with is that you
could take a [ __ ] in a Ghoulie could
each actually maybe go to the bathroom
or
yeah you know your VHS collective like
two tapes yeah and then yeah but gooeys
earlier that's not not part of the
master selection when did you realize
that made a mistake he'd heard it wrong
right soon as I opened it up it was just
like try to watch it oh yeah I still
watch it I watched it multiple times
yeah yeah I got three tastes terrible
what else is in the VHS collection I
feel like it was cloak and dagger and
Revenge of the Nerds those four the
other your badass movies here [ __ ]
ghoulia what cloak and dagger remember
that it was like the kid the kid played
the video game and uh in there was like
people after them and you've never seen
cloak and Dan yeah as art of it I don't
know if I've ever seen it but I know
yeah I know the movie so like is this
are you thinking when you start to do or
was this something you were thinking for
a long time or do you feel like okay I
got the aliens movie here I can start
moving into horror over here I can
finally start to kind of branch out of I
should think about things that
strategically but I know I talk no it
was a totally by chance it was David
just called me one day and was like hey
would you want to just write this thing
with me and help me produce it was like
yeah sure I know how hard maybes work I
was just on the set of one I'll show you
yeah I guess it is kind of a horror
movie I mean I 5 it is more horror yeah
it was out so it was awesome on the set
of that is like you know there's a
pretty grisly stuff that happens in that
film and like you just see Ridley on set
just giggling he loves it he loves the
blood the gore it's like the same way I
would feel like making a movie when I
was like in high school or something he
just gets off on it but it is hard to
keep it to keep it scary when you when
people like you said you know Michael
Mars is not gonna be killable with the
alien you know it's not going to work
out like when they find an alien and
they're headed back Ridley Scott
directed it's not going to be a nice
alien yeah so yeah harder to build the
suspense as you know there's going to be
a problem you know it's just I think
because they're tapping into that weird
parasite vibe but like something infects
your body and I don't know I think it
just plays on like weird vibes of being
sick and like you can't imagine that
happening to yourself I go I go away on
the trip and I'm the guy who gets
infected with something yeah you're
right about about horror movies being
like one of the only things that people
go see in theaters anymore like the
bloom house you know bloom house the
production company every
they do yeah makes a ton of money and
it's all good like I love all those
movies are they horror yeah yeah yeah I
love or they do all like the conjuring
stuff although terrifying and they just
did get out like all those other they're
doing Halloween actually oh really oh
really they know your strength hey just
being shown in IMAX her in 3d I think it
is being shown in IMAX yep it's not 3d I
don't know if it's 3d is it 3d maybe no
I think just I meant just I'm a kind of
a good 3d movie I'll see something that
I might not have normally seen just to
see it in three days yeah I don't know
what are they making people regret their
decisions alright this one's not in 3d
but so and I'm accessing it hi Mac I'm
still great okay all right yeah good
this is what kind of shine screen I know
I would like to heat it a lot yes have
you seen it uh you know I have exceeded
twice now and uh even if I wasn't in
this film you'd like it yeah I think
it's awesome did you have any idea how
good Walton Goggins was going to be on
vice principal we knew we knew there was
a sick bastard we were we were thrilled
to happen yeah it was funny when we were
first talking about it they were we were
being pitched a lot of just comedic
actors and we were like man we need
somebody more dangerous and more [ __ ]
up and Walton Goggins was was the guy
yeah I mean he's I don't know if you see
I stood I saw the first couple he's
brilliant on the show and it's one of
those things you wouldn't necessarily
see coming it's not it's not a casting
they did you would as a person at home
would just be like well yeah of course
yeah he's awesome in the second season
which comes out later this year it
really digs in deep with his guy he does
some pretty wild [ __ ] he's he's great do
you like doing cuz it's the last season
right yeah we you know we did the whole
we wrote the whole series as just one
piece of eighteen episodes and Shiloh
islands yeah so it's like it was made to
you know conclusion second season time
of yeah so you didn't know if you're
going to do three six episode seasons or
two nine yeah we did two nine but that
was just always our plan like we
finished all the scripts before we shot
anything we said yeah just uh you know I
don't know I love TV but the one thing I
don't like about TV is like when you get
invested in the show and then it kind of
shits the bed after you've already
invested you know weeks of your time and
so for us we were like let's just make
something complete and people have to
worry about it [ __ ] the bed don't
like it or they don't and then it's over
with see you later you just tell them
like you said we want to sell you
eighteen episodes or something yeah yeah
that's a pretty big that did they make
you shoot a pilot before they made a
decision cuz if they if they do that
then you got a pilot shot and seventeen
episodes that you went we we didn't we
didn't shoot a pilot in Austin we
thought that was a win but that what
made it more difficult to use it when
you shoot a pilot you have a chance to
assess like what's working what's not
worry with this was like I don't even
think we started shooting the first
episode I think we actually like started
on like parts of the third episode we
just we know we wrote the whole thing
and then we're just off to the races he
didn't almost that you filmed it like a
9-hour yeah exactly
Wow it's great they're not going to
cancel if they know there's only 18
they'll just show ya exactly what can
they do it's also good because like the
same thing is eastbound and down like
you ended at a certain point and then if
Fillmore dries up at some point go back
in and you can only like you say the
Vice their little it was meant to be but
oh well luckily if everything dries up
in ten years I'm another 18 episode
right but you know it was originally
intended to be that but I have this
inspiration
well there is character be liked it end
when they don't know how to end
something it doesn't it just like like
lost I thought was so great but the I
didn't love the certain parts about the
ending which again no matter what you're
surprised most people complain about
when they don't know how to end
something that can really hurt it you
can see sometimes when they're grabbing
in the final season like they don't have
enough to hold you they did they just
they're just trying too many new ideas
it's weird yeah and also I think what
happens too is that your interaction
with the fans is like every time there's
a new season you get kind of feedback on
what people like and what they don't
like and I think sometimes it makes
writers kind of gravitate towards what
people are liking and I might not
necessarily be what's the coolest part
of the show yeah I always think that
those series to go on a long time a
gloss or Sopranos or something I'm sure
there was an ending in mind when the
show first started like this is the arc
I see it going in but there's no way
after you do all those seasons that you
still have the ending in mind like by
the time you get to season seven you're
just kind of making [ __ ] up if you go
like I guess this would kind of start it
off yourself
yeah let me kill him do we not kill him
hey we look to a Sopranos movie yeah I
mean exactly that that's why they didn't
care Dexter they wanted to kill the
writers wanted to kill him and Showtime
said no really money is always a bad
decision but they wanted to make a film
or something that was I heard of the
is a lot of times the writers want to do
it yeah yeah I think they just get bored
I'm sure they want to just write it out
new people yeah exactly I mean that's
what it was even with us on eastbound
like we were planning eastbound to be
done after the third season and we went
in and pitched them vice-principals and
they were like we'll do vice-principals
but you have to do one more season of
eastbound and so I don't know I love
writing for that show but like anything
after a while you're like man I want to
write something that doesn't involve a
guy who throws baseballs and has a
mullet
I want to write another stuff yeah sure
sure I think that was a Stallone deal I
think the reason he did the last Rocky
movie was because he wanted to do
another Rambo or vice versa oh and they
were like well we'll do another Rambo
but you got to do another Rocky or
something like I love that new Rambo I
just said they're smiling the whole time
of all that [ __ ] carnage yeah I don't
never I didn't see it was good right I
thought it was awesome but yeah it was
just like what we have know is supposed
to be it was just people getting the
[ __ ] blown out of them for the whole
movie like the bad guys are never
developed you just know there's one bad
guy with sunglasses and that's just the
leader of the bad guys it's like it's
like the last scene of Scarface but for
an entire movie yeah yeah why does
Anurag you is good I like that I mean
you know rocky fights cancer like all
right from the ring with the Battle of
his life getting an IV bottle but it was
still it was good if you look kind of
human he looked old a lie like that I
don't like to get tired of the macho
[ __ ] last night in the I got in here
late last night and watched uh I
couldn't go to sleep so I rent it Logan
on TV I hadn't seen that yet [ __ ] that
was awesome I tried it Logan yeah it was
projected it yes I went on a date up and
I cried and waffle movie cook you should
take off your 3d glasses I cried I did I
was just doing the old dab I was doing
the back of the finger damn yeah it was
it was really good though I like
superhero movie that I loved it it was
great I'll be not just like seeing those
claws go through people's faces and
skulls it was just like wow this is
Amanda kid you like that part gem and
hit him on more of an emotional level I
was hit by that as well like every time
I leave my family I always get like
these weird dark thoughts about network
what will happen if I if I'm something
happens that I never come back and my
son has to be raised by my neighbor or
something so I was just watching that
like and looking it's a pretty badass
dad I guess I said maybe I should be
like him more
how old is your son he's five so you're
your mom hasn't wanted to do puppet
shows for him not yet I think we're
going to
get him into the business maybe he can
continue you want you to which you would
you want her to do it religiously or not
uh whatever she would want all yeah yeah
I wouldn't care so didn't you you don't
have it do you have anything that you
can show him in terms of your work he
you know I don't but he still watches a
lot of the stuff he knows about he knows
what Dad does very words I mean we like
play a little game all the time when his
mom's gone where we just like what go in
front of the Apple TV and just start
watching trailers and we'll start with
something very innocent and then by the
end it's like to the predator trailer
yes I'm testing him seeing what he's
made of
what did he like you know really he
doesn't like cartoons he likes stuff
with real people in it lying awesome
something like the predator trailer
didn't spook him at all but then
watching Zootopia he has to sleep in my
room for like three weeks it's like what
is utopia it's a Disney movie I'm like a
cartoon I didn't watch it but something
happens where someone's eyes get big and
they get angry and that's like all I
hear about all laughing Wow yeah Wow but
it's a you watch your predator yeah look
come on let's calm down let's watch
predator trailering scan but the whole
movie might that works out great for you
no it's great yeah because every other
parent like complains about the fact
that to watch cartoons all the time yeah
no he's a yeah like we showed him
Goonies because obviously that's
important you didn't have enough good
yeah not good Lily's will wait on I
don't remember goodies I saw it I don't
remember it oh dear amazing yeah I was
one of my favorite movies as a kid and
even recently what was my son's spring
break from from elementary school and I
took them to took my family to Portland
and we rented a car and drove to a story
where they shot The Goonies and they
have like the Goonies house is there
really the jail that they break out of
in the beginning is like The Goonies
Museum it was awesome that's amazing
yeah I think Goonies is so respected I
feel like now like movie studios still
when they want to do some kind of family
movie around kids but everybody can
watch they still love to do like we want
to do something like a Goonies type like
a Goonies type it's still thrown I know
I've seen it I just don't mind by the
way Danny is promoting a alien covenant
in theaters this Friday I don't even
need to mention everybody knows well you
know I saw the trailer for is it does it
freak you out at all like or do you care
about the bye
surface of this movie uh like you want
people to see it like she want people to
you hope that people dig it and yeah put
your time into it and you hope people
like show up and see it yeah be great
does it freak you out when like what was
it King Arthur with the movie that came
out a bomb seventeen million dollars or
something a fourteen minutes almost like
a hundred seventy-five million to make
and and like looking at the trailers and
stuff it's one that who's in it
the guy from Sons of Anarchy yeah I
really wanted to be King Arthur's is not
that it's a bad movie but like a lot of
totally honest I don't care a lot about
King Arthur at this point I'm not a
masseuse on but it's so much do we need
it looks super badass like it look okay
does that like freaked you out at all
like that seems like a movie that would
do well uh it does a free books it's
kind of you know it's hard to know what
will work or what doesn't so you know
it's not my money and I hoped I'd just
hope that people dig it yeah yeah are
you kind of happy are you kind of happy
with other movie should to bed because
then your movie will look better uh no
true nobody's going this week I love
what I'm watching a comedian if he goes
up there and his death and he's sweating
through his shirt off but there's no way
I'm gonna look this bad no I've never
looked at it that way but maybe I should
yeah yeah you know it's not like
anybody's going this right here some
King Arthur like that Dungy you know now
now that now that feels wide open for
the alien movie you also think like all
that money that people would have spent
on something they'll spend on your movie
like you know people have so much money
to go out yeah and watch a movie yeah I
guess you know I know
just [ __ ] guessing never kills you
look she's trying to be related exactly
take any more lunch bottles we only got
a few dollars if you shut up Jim talking
about people who are the movies every
weekend they get people get their
allowance every week but still what
happens yeah I know with the quickie the
stories have an [ __ ] your
government-funded movie allowance comes
in how long the apply won't be long
before it winds up on on TV on iTunes
and movies wind up there really fast
okay you look like two months or so
later yeah that note yeah yeah
so going right to video is no longer
humiliating yeah no digital releases uh
it's a big thing it's not great but it's
not as not Vangelis yeah I don't mind it
because like I said I have kids and so
if I get a sitter I don't want to just
sit in the movie theater you know so I
don't mind seeing those box-office
movies in my the comfort of my home I
like yeah
you know there's a horror movie that
came out digital release as I thought I
was going to hate but I just decided to
buy it on iTunes and it's called clown
you see the movie clown I haven't seen
about know what you're talking about it
was actually really is like turning into
a clown slowly right fathers agrees a
clown outfit and you can't take it off I
want to see that yeah it's really good
it's brutal - I interview on not that I
want to see her a chip chip person but
chip in the next episode is a chip as a
clown and the interviews a woman who is
a clown trip Jefferson is Jim's concert
Iannetta for control well we just talked
about this this woman this woman was
against a lot of clowns hate that [ __ ]
yeah drives him crazy
always like they don't like they hate it
they hate it they hate all of these
movies that make clowns look bad
yeah and it's got to be pretty annoying
if you dedicate yourself to being a
clown and then you see [ __ ] like
poltergeist and you're like god damn it
yeah and set our industry back decades
yeah yet literally in the movie clown
the clown eats children but I think we
got a really worst-case scenario Bert
want to be a happy clown dancing I ask
all your stupid probably the clowns that
make money doing bouncing a ball how
humiliating really tough to make money
uh being a scary clown because it
definitely feels like they've put Ronald
McDonald on the bench I feel like he's
they're not leading McDonald's is never
really leading with Ronald McDonald no
no no now you got just a bunch of cool
like too cool kids on side out there
yeah you don't need no need a clown -
nobody wants to see that these clowns is
just somebody anything creepy about an
adult that interacts with kids these
days is also a little creepy so Ronald
her kids you're like [ __ ] are you that's
true or any or any figure you know
unless you're in a full costume you're
like a goat or elephant yeah if you're
like a man dressed as a kid that's been
some dress - the way the kids like it's
just seen as weird though yeah when you
see that white makeup and you can see
beads of sweat on their forehead it just
seems creepy yeah
that's a human thing oh my god is it a
man there's a Latino man yeah fingers
smell inside those you know if you if
you if it's a movie about someone
killing kids that's okay but if you're
like if it's like someone that could be
kind of creepy Asian like a bit handsy
or like her or the drunk clown that
shows up at Uncle Buck
[Laughter]
daddy was important and my memories
going do you remember uncle Wang yes I
did great movie I wish John Candy was
aligned you do you know him he's not now
in castellón oh listen to ya we mean for
you to find out he wasn't funny as
though wasn't he was funny all right
every movie showed up in amazing did you
ever work on my no I was I think like
yeah always yeah I remember it well baby
how old you know I'm 48
I'm 40 yeah a night 30 years ago Jackie
and II was way dead by the time we're
done a bride's first Roy can you hear
that now she was in the 90s right you
might be definitely died in the 90s like
it yeah well Harry crumb was like his
last big movie I think he had like a
western movie or something that was one
of his last ones yeah yeah I can't
remember what your do you have a
favorite thing that you've done or do
you not reflect like that
or just maybe something you had the best
time doing oh you know any of this
honestly up I've been lucky enough to
like almost everything I've worked on
I've had a good time on you know stuff
like my principles and eastbound is fun
because it's all all the guys that we I
went to college with work on that show
so that's pretty sweet but uh everything
spawning alien is awesome I mean when
you show up to work on something like
this and you're just you know walking
around with guns and there's aliens
chasing you it's awesome it doesn't seem
like work did your college friends that
you do stuff with get insecure when you
started working with the Franco crew in
the Apatow crew like whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa we kind of had a road
thing going on over here if you're not
bringing them along just they're like
yeah I guess this is the end but that's
more like you and their friends right
like you're not in that it was kind of
like we were swinging they're like it's
okay if you go there but you got to
bring them to our party every day okay
9400 a giant panda died so yeah I know
I'm wrong
what was I 18 years old okay okay cool
yeah that was the idea I didn't know
give over Spencer Tracy
[ __ ] you're not doing anything with
the a disaster artist movie are you I
you know what I'm a I did an interview
for it so I think I'm like a talking
head interview for like the disaster
artist that's the movie about the making
of the room yeah it's pretty are you in
that just like an inner I've never seen
the whole room oh you
oh I used to watch it like me my friends
would like watch it like once a year not
very well acted that's pretty amazing
though it's great my favorite interview
I've ever done is with Tommy oh wow
I had Tommy was so in here for an hour
once and he was like as Tommy was so as
you could possibly imagine there's no
and then off the air he was even more
Tommy was oh I love like you know when I
first moved to LA there was always like
a billboard that I think it was on
labret or something that was always like
the room and it was Tommy's faces like
call for bookings of screenings or
something it was up there for years and
I was like what that is this is his cell
phone number is that what his own phone
but it was like definitely being
presented as if it was a hard-hitting
drama and then like years later it was
being rebranded as a dark comedy no was
it because he thought it was going to be
nominated for an Academy Award so he
like looked into everything like you
needed theatrical release and you needed
this so he bought himself the Billboard
and then he started booking theaters
himself because he wanted to present to
the Academy that this is this is the
real thing is eligible for an Oscar that
movie is amazing and even if you just
look at it from the standpoint of a
writer it's like every scene starts with
the characters like entering the room
they say what they have to say then they
all leave the room everything is like hi
hi how's it going good to see you okay
that they talk about bye-bye and they
also every scene is written like in your
head I have to introduce them yes that
is pretty poor right that's amazing
yeah I've seen scenes from the scenes
I've seen were very funny very enjoyable
when you did foot first wait did you buy
all the equipment or did you read this I
think we bought I think we bought a
large portion of the budget of the
$50,000 budget way to get the gear tommy
was so purchased everything which and
any and he shot it on film and HD video
and everything he did not rent a goddamn
thing he can't think he overspent he did
overspend a little bit yeah
I just love it I love it I can revisit
that movie any time it's brilliant
you have to rap with Danny they're
telling us we can have movies you're
going to be able to revisit any time
good one remember
alien covenant is out this Friday in
theaters and this is good because I like
to I like to still go to the movie
theaters and this is the exact like a
movie like this is the exact reason why
yeah you should still go this is
something that you want to watch in a
theater you know you want to get your
popcorn you want to do the whole deal
this is this is a movie that will it
will be lacking and from a home theater
so I would totally agree the sound
design on this visual effects the whole
deal I mean really thinks about it all
so it's really Scott Lee this is a guy
who was who was raised making film for
film projector movie theaters yeah so I
don't think we needed the popcorn wanna
know what's in that daily dollars and
you don't sustain a picture you can have
hotdogs you get your popcorn to simmer
down a very wide variety exactly bring
your own snacks if you need we know yeah
you can save a little money all right